[Música]
son las 8 y 30 de la noche en bogotá
quito y lima continuamos en directo
américa edición nocturna seguimos
comentando los los principales hechos
del día les agradecemos su sintonía y
vamos con los titulares de esta jornada
la ciudad de severodonezk sigue siendo
el foco de la ofensiva rusa por capturar
la totalidad de la región de lugansk en
ucrania autoridades locales han
reportado fuertes ataques con morteros y
artillería entretanto las tropas
ucranianas recibieron armas donadas por
francia
tras salir victorioso de una moción de
censura dentro del partido conservador
el primer ministro británico gordon song
aseguró que el resultado es
extremadamente bueno así se concluye un
nuevo capítulo del escándalo por las
fiestas ilegales en downing street
durante la pandemia
una multitudinaria caravana de migrantes
salió desde el sur de méxico rumbo a
eeuu
justamente el tema migratorio es punto
clave en la agenda de la novena cumbre
de las américas que comenzó en los ã
ngeles un encuentro marcado por varias
ausencias
[Música]
[Aplausos]
damos comienzo en ucrania la ofensiva
rusa continúa enfocada en lograr el
control de la ciudad de severodonezk un
punto clave que le permitiría a las
tropas rusas hacerse con el control
total de la región de lugansk las
autoridades locales informaron sobre los
constantes ataques con morteros y
artillería parte de la estrategia rusa
es provocar la mayor destrucción de la
infraestructura de la ciudad para que
las tropas ucranianas no tengan nada que
defender por otra parte el ejército de
quien recibió un lote de armas que fue
prometido y donado por francia el mes
pasado en abril para apoyar la defensa
ucraniana veamos los detalles
son algunas de las últimas armas que han
llegado al frente ucraniano
estos son los cañones autopropulsados
césar enviados por francia ahora en el
corazón del conflicto en el donbass
el objetivo de hoy es la artillería rusa
situada a sólo 17 km
este es el sonido de los ataques que
alcanzan su objetivo apenas 4 minutos y
20 segundos después de llegar a este
campo de tiro esta unidad del ejército
ucraniano vuelve a salir buscando evitar
que las fuerzas rusas respondan
de vuelta a su base este soldado
ucraniano hace un balance con la ayuda
de drones que sobrevuelan el objetivo
después del disparo
estas imágenes de un ataque anterior
muestran resulta mente los daños tanques
enemigos destruidos y junto a ellos
cuerpos de soldados rusos
ese día debió ser realmente abrumador
para el enemigo
y los soldados que sobrevivieron al
ataque ese día trataron de correr y
esconderse bajo los árboles
con la ayuda de seis cañones cesan está
unidad dice haber aniquilado más de 80
piezas de artillería rusa hace apenas un
mes estos jóvenes soldados fueron
entrenados para utilizar los cañones en
una base militar en el sur de francia
nos enviaron a francia para aprender a
disparar con los camiones césar nos
dieron mucha información teníamos que
aprenderlo todo lo más rápido posible
solo teníamos dos semanas de
entrenamiento
el césar es capaz de disparar seis
rondas en un minuto
cuando buses de un alcance de hasta 40
km los cañones están montados sobre
camiones una configuración que el
ejército ucraniano dice que salva vidas
el ejército ruso utiliza técnicas
modernas de vigilancia y drones para
atacarnos por lo que es importante que
no permanezcamos demasiado tiempo en el
campo de tiro no podemos darle tiempo de
volver los disparos el césar es muy
fácil de maniobrar nos permite salir
rápidamente
ucrania cuenta con estas armadas junto
con otros sistemas de misiles de países
como eeuu y el reino unido- para
reforzar su ofensiva contra el ejército
ruso
en reino unido el primer ministro boris
johnson calificó como una victoria el
haber superado la moción de censura
dentro del partido conservador el primer
británico logró el apoyo del 59% de los
diputados de su partido y reiteró que
planea seguir al frente del gobierno
asimismo despejó dudas sobre la
posibilidad de convocar elecciones
anticipadas estas fueron sus palabras
creo que este es un resultado muy bueno
para la política y para el país en este
sentido creo que es un resultado
contundente un resultado decisivo y lo
que significa es que como gobierno
podemos seguir adelante y enfocarnos en
las cosas que creo que realmente le
importan a la gente
que somos a tivoli marsans este tipo en
otras noticias vamos a nigeria donde
continúan las investigaciones sobre el
tiroteo que dejó al menos 50 personas
fallecidas y una decena de heridos los
hechos ocurrieron durante un servicio
religioso en la ciudad de agua al
suroeste del país africano la masacre ha
conmocionado a la nación que está
acostumbrada a los hechos de violencia
por parte de grupos radicales en los
estados del norte
además del silencio la iglesia católica
de san francisco en la ciudad nigeriana
de hoy lo único que queda es destrucción
el suelo y las paredes manchadas de
sangre de las víctimas pruebas del
tiroteo que dejó decenas de muertos el
domingo en plena misa
cuando la misa estaba a punto de
terminar oímos disparos así que todo el
mundo empezó a correr yo mismo corrí
hacia el lado del retrete y me caí allí
y me arrastré hasta la parte de atrás y
una madera en la pared la empujé con la
pierna y me caía al otro lado así escape
los criminales atacaron sin ni siquiera
entrar en el lugar de culto lanzando
dinamita y disparando desde las ventanas
en plena festividad de pentecostés ahora
decenas de heridos se recuperan en el
centro médico federal muchos de ellos a
menores
volví corriendo a la iglesia y vi a mis
dos hijos y los trajimos aquí al centro
médico también vi a muchos heridos y a
los muertos
ander
antxía en nigeria hablamos de
inseguridad y se cursi con las banderas
nacionales a media asta en honor a las
víctimas el ejecutivo ha declarado siete
días de luto nacional
les aseguro que sin duda encontraremos a
quienes lo perpetraron
los pescamos y pagarán las consecuencias
de este atroz crimen con sus dos vecinos
cual desde el gobierno acusa en un
crimen de odio claramente dirigido
contra los cristianos católicos pero
todavía no se ha detenido ni
identificado a ninguno de los autores
del crimen
la ciudad de los ángeles en california
eeuu es el escenario de la novena cumbre
de las américas evento que comenzó en la
jornada de hoy el anfitrión el
presidente joe biden espera estrechar y
fortalecer los lazos con el resto del
continente sin embargo la casa blanca no
invitó a representantes de los gobiernos
de cuba nicaragua y venezuela lo que
llevó a otros mandatarios a no asistir
al evento amor a sí mismo el mandatario
uruguayo luis lacalle pou no está
presente por ser diagnosticado con kobe
y a propósito de este encuentro
diplomático hoy una nueva caravana de
miles de migrantes partido del sur de
méxico rumbo a estados unidos los
migrantes esperan hacer coordinar su
llegada con la cumbre de las américas
que se desarrollan los angeles ya lo
decíamos entretanto la organización
human rights watch publicó un informe en
el cual denuncia abusos sistemáticos
contra migrantes por parte de
autoridades de eeuu y méxico en su
frontera común
es una de las caravanas de inmigrantes
más grandes de los últimos años más de
6000 personas mayoritariamente de
venezuela huyen de la violencia y de las
condiciones precarias la caravana salió
de tapachula en el sur de méxico donde
los migrantes han estado esperando sin
conseguir visas humanitarias y vaya eeuu
hermano tenemos ya casi un mes aquí y no
lo han solucionado lo de la visa
humanitaria
queremos un futuro para nuestra familia
no somos violentos coordinaron su
recorrido con el inicio de la cumbre de
las américas que empezó este lunes en
los ángeles y se espera que aborde el
tema de la migración el presidente de
lópez obrador decidió creo
cumbre de las américas nosotros le
pedimos como seres humanos de la
hispanoamérica que se pongan de acuerdo
son demasiadas personas migrantes
de lo que han querido convertir a
tapachula en una gran cárcel migratoria
este lunes la organización human rights
watch publicó un informe denunciando
abusos sistemáticos por parte de eeuu y
méxico contra los migrantes la
externalización de control migratorio de
eeuu a méxico ha dado lugar a graves
abusos y ha obligado a cientos de miles
de personas a esperar en condiciones
espantosas para buscar protección a la
ong denuncia la política del presidente
joe biden que ha presionado a méxico
para aumentar las restricciones para
ingresar y viajar dentro del país
haciendo aún más difícil para los
solicitantes de asilo de obtener
protección y haciendo de su viaje hacia
eeuu una travesía más peligrosa human
rights watch pidió a los jefes de estado
del continente
comprometerse para asegurar protección
para los migrantes
en otras noticias el ministro de
medioambiente de recursos naturales de
república dominicana orlando jorge mera
fue asesinado a tiros en su oficina así
lo confirmó el gobierno del presidente y
luís abinader las autoridades señalaron
que el atacante identificado como miguel
cruz era amigo de la infancia del
ministro y fue capturado aún no se
conocen sus motivaciones para ampliar
esta información conectamos con argenis
a romero ella es escritora y reportera
de república dominicana bienvenida a
france 24 que otros detalles se conocen
de este crimen
buenas noches
hace pocos minutos el ministerio público
de república dominicana informó que
el señalado autor del crimen confesó el
asesinato y que en las próximas horas se
presentará la acusación formal en su
contra
todavía el cadáver del ministro se
encuentra en el instituto social
nacional de ourense en espera de la
autopsia
bueno y que ha representado a la imagen
del ministro mera entre la sociedad
dominicana
era un ministro
muy valorado por la sociedad dominicana
y alguien muy cercano a las luchas
medioambientales desde antes de ser
ministro de medio ambiente
también con un historial político
bastante extenso desde su juventud
orlando jorge mera es era hijo del ex
presidente de la república salvador
jorge blanco que gobernó república
dominicana entre 1982 y 1986 desde muy
joven era abogado pero desde muy joven
se incluyen las filas políticas del
partido revolucionario dominicano que en
ese momento era el partido de su padre y
ahí militó dentro de la juventud del
partido de reproducciones de dominicanos
y ya luego de la separación de un grupo
importante de este partido ejerció como
presidente en funciones de
partido revolucionario moderno partido
del gobierno actual hasta los de 2015 a
2019 cuando pasarás a ser delegado del
psm ante la junta central electora y
luego en 2020 cuando luís abinader ganó
la presidencia de la república fue
nombrado ministro de medio ambiente
genera usted muchas gracias por su
análisis por compartir esta información
con nosotros en france 24
gracias por la invitación en otras
noticias este domingo 12 de junio tiene
lugar la primera vuelta de las
elecciones legislativas en francia
semanas atrás los partidos de izquierda
unieron esfuerzos para hacer una sola
campaña con miras a ganar la mayoría en
la asamblea y así hacer oposición a la
bancada del recientemente reelecto
presidente emmanuel mccall
el mundial marco puede haber ganado la
presidencia pero ahora su agenda depende
de los resultados de las legislativas
en las que enfrenta la izquierda
unificada
los líderes del partido francia insumisa
los socialistas los ecologistas y los
comunistas han formado una coalición a
la que llaman ni un acrónimo que
significa la nueva unión popular
ecológica y social su objetivo es simple
llegar con una mayoría a la asamblea
nacional para bloquear la agenda de
macon y hacer avanzar la propia
el líder del partido comunista incluso
llevar la campaña puerta a puerta las
leyes no se hacen en el elíseo se hacen
en la asamblea y si hay una nueva
mayoría en la asamblea el presidente
está obligado a cambiar de gobierno y de
primer ministro y a nombrar un gobierno
de izquierda hay que explicárselo a la
gente es lo primero que tenemos que
hacer y lo que hacemos todos los días la
cabeza del partido francia en su misión
luis veloso quedó en un reñido tercer
puesto en la primera vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales y ahora aspira
a ser nombrado como primer ministro con
un portón lo que traemos es otra visión
del mundo de la sociedad no les digo que
de la noche a la mañana crearemos un
paraíso pero les garantizo que de la
noche a la mañana acabaremos con el
infierno
pero el apoyo a la nueva unión popular
no es generalizado varios pequeños
partidos ecologistas se han declarado en
contra de la coalición de izquierdas y
han apoyado a 250 candidatos distintos
en las elecciones legislativas y
terminamos esta informativo en brasil
donde autoridades indígenas denunciaron
que el periodista británico don philips
colaborador del diario the guardian y el
indigenista brasileño bruno araújo
pereira desaparecieron el domingo en el
valle de javarí una de las regiones más
remotas de la amazonía en un comunicado
informaron que araujo un profundo
conocedor de la zona había recibido
amenazas desde hace unos días por parte
de invasores
así llegamos al final de esta misión de
directo américa les agradecemos su
sintonía y los invitamos a continuar con
nosotros que ya llega a malvinas con
toda la actualidad del continente
africano en áfrica siete días feliz
noche para todos
[Música]